Hey everyone, let's say that you have estimated what your demand and supply functions look like.
But what you really need to know is what price you can expect the market and what quantity you can expect the market to give to you for this.
So what we want to do is figure out those equilibrium prices and quantities so you can make the best decisions that you can make.
So let's say that you estimated the quantity demand function to be 180 minus 3p and the quantity supplied function to be minus 20 plus 5p.
So we have the minus sign in front of the P and that lets us know that we're dealing with the law of demand.
We have this positive sign in front of that 5P, and that lets us know that we are dealing with the law of supply.
Now, to find the equilibrium price, what we need to do is set our quantity supplied equal to our quantity demand, or vice versa.
It's all the same.
And this is going to give us minus 20 plus 5p is equal to 180 minus 3p.
All right, now what we want to do is solve down for P.
So I'm going to pull the -3p over to the left hand side and the -20 over to the right hand side.
And this is going to give me 8p equals 200.
Now when I solve for P, we know that price is going to end up being $25.
So that is the equilibrium price.
Now to find the equilibrium quantity.
And let's just make sure we have that highlighted there.  Nice.
To find the equilibrium quantity, all we need to do is take this $25 and plug it either into this function or this function and we will get the equilibrium quantity.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Let's take that 25 and let's plug it into that first equation.
So this is going to give me QD equals 180 minus 3 times 25.
So that is 180 minus 75.
And so my quantity is going to be 105.
Now, I could plug it into this equation, the quantity supplied equation as well, and, and I would get the same thing.
So I now know what my equilibrium price and my equilibrium quantities are.
But if I did want to graph this just to have something nice to look at, I cannot use these, cannot use these here because those do not relate right with the graph orientation.
So instead what I need to do is solve for P instead of solving for Q like what we previously did.
So here all I'm going to do is take this equation, this demand function and this supply function and solve it down for P itself.
So this is going to give me QD is equal to 180 minus 3p.  Alright.
So let's pull the 180 over to the other side.
This gives me QD minus 108.
That's not a 180.
So QD minus 180 is equal to minus 3p.
Divide both sides by the minus 3 and what we're going to end up getting is 60 minus 0.33 QD is equal to P.
Now let's do the same thing.
For quantity supplied, we had Qs is equal to minus 20 plus 5p.
Let's pull the minus 20 over to the other side.
Now we have QS QS, let's rewrite that.
We have QS.
20 is equal to 5p and simply divide the entire thing by 5.
And what we end up with is 4 plus QS.
That should be 4 plus 0.2 QS.
And let's put that back in there.
4 plus 0.2 QS is equal to P.
Now I have my supply curve and now I have my demand curve.
I can take these functions and put them into a graph.
So let's do that.
Let's draw in our price and our quantity axis.
And we're going to have our supply curve upward sloping.
And so this starts at a price of four, because that's what we determined right here with that intercept.
And our demand curve is going to start at A.
That's a terrible looking demand curve.
But our demand curve starts at a price of 60, as we determined right here.
And we know that they achieve an equilibrium at this point where our quantity demand equals our quantity supplied.
And we determined that price was $25.
And we know that our equilibrium output was 105.
So this is our supply curve, this is our demand curve.
We could rewrite these to be this is 60 minus 0.33 q.
And this one was 4 plus 0.2 q as well.
And that is how we find the supply and demand functions.
That is how we find the equilibrium price.
And that's how we also find the equilibrium quantity.
With those demand and supply functions that we have here.
We can also figure out where we would have shortages, where we would have surpluses if we simply altered what the price happened to be.
If the price was equal to 30 as opposed to 25, then what we would see is a price, or excuse me, a quantity demand would be 180 minus 90.
So our quantity demand would be 90.
Our quantity supplied, we would have 5 times 30, which is 150, 150 minus the 20 is going to give us a quantity supplied of 130.
So come back to our graph, and let's go in here and add in a price of $30.
And what we're going to see, our quantity demand is going to be 90.
Our quantity supplied is going to be 120.
And that difference between those two is 30.  30.
So our quantity supplied right here is greater than our quantity demand right there.
This gives us a surplus.
And what we're going to do is put downward pressure on that price of $30 in order to get back to the market clearing price of $25.  All right, that is it.
Hope you've enjoyed it, and I'll catch you in our next one.